hillarie blames every single person in
america except for you-know-who for her
election loss plus we talked about
President Trump and whether he's about
to cut a deal with Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck Schumer and I give you the full
Berkeley update plus should ESPN fire
Jamel Hill we'll talk about it I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show so
tomorrow
hurricane Ben makes landfall in Berkeley
is apparently the headline that we're
getting from the left-wing media and we
will explain to you what exactly is
gonna happen tomorrow at Berkeley and
how you can get standby tickets they are
sold out but there is talk about a bunch
of protesters having taken tickets and
then walking out until we have a standby
line I'll explain to you how you can
take advantage of that plus I will give
you the entire rundown on Hillary
Clinton and why the Democrats are now
saying that Trump may actually be
President Trump man should be Teflon
I'll explain why that might be true and
why it might not be true but before we
do any of that first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at helix sleep
so as I have said before I am terrible
at sleep or at least I was terrible at
sleep up until we got our helix sleep
mattress there are a lot of online
mattress retailers and they're popping
up these days all with this
one-size-fits-all solution but helix
sleep has a proprietary algorithm they
look at your weight how you how it's
distributed across your body they run it
through their algorithm they asks what
sort of mattress you want to want it
firm do you want it soft do you want
them to be breathable do you want to
absorb heat and then they send a
mattress directly to your door you pop
up in the box and it inflates right
before you because it's a foam mattress
it is supremely comfortable my wife
particularly loves it it's helix sleep
calm /ban you can take their simple two
to three minutes sleep quiz and they
build that customer mattress that is the
best thing you've ever slept on it also
allows you to have different settings
for one side versus the other so if my
wife wanted to sleep on a different type
mattress than I did they can create a
mattress that has two different sides to
it everyone from GQ to Cosmopolitan to
the New York Times talking about helix
sleep and there's a reason for it your
custom mattress arrives directly to the
door in a week and shipping is
completely free try it for a hundred
nights and if you don't like it you
don't love it they'll pick it up and
they will refund you in full right now
go to helix sleep comm slash Ben you get
a $50 discount toward your custom
mattress again helix sleep comm slash
Ben use that slash Ben you get a $50
discount toward your custom mattress
again that's helix
we calm / been most comfortable mattress
I've slept on and again use that / Benz
that they know that we sent you and they
and they understand that their
advertising is working well okay so the
the big story of the day is of course
Hillary Clinton continuing to make the
rounds before I get to that I want to
explain how you get tickets to the
Berkeley speech so it is sold out they
sold out all of the tickets in 45
minutes they had actually closed the
other thousand seats we would have sold
that out to probably in the first 45
minutes as well except that they closed
the upper tier at this auditorium
Zellerbach Hall at Berkeley they closed
it because they were afraid that an sefa
members were going to infiltrate and
actually rip I guess the the chairs off
the floor I think they're bolted em
they're gonna rip the chairs off the
floor and then start flinging them down
onto the unsuspecting crowd members
below which is just insane the answer to
that by the way is more security not
banning a thousand people from the hall
that's that's absurd but in any case
Berkeley does seem to be doing what they
should be doing for security Berkeley
City Council today or last night passed
a vote six to three
that said that the Berkeley PD are
allowed to use pepper spray on violent
offenders how this is even a question is
beyond me but I guess I am the cause of
that so yay me it's about time they
started using pepper spray on people who
get violent their rioters they are not
protesters once they start getting
violent apparently there's been a 20
year ban in place on using pepper spray
against violent protesters because
Berkeley is one of the world's dumbest
places so if you want to get standby
tickets then you can go over to the the
Berkeley College you can go over to the
Berkeley campus tomorrow for those who
reserved to ticket online you have to
pick up your tickets at a time prior to
6:30 p.m. on Thursday September 14th any
tickets that are unclaimed by 6:30 p.m.
will be forfeited by those who reserved
them and they're setting up a standby
line right now there's a standby line
forming a Memorial Stadium box office at
the UC Berkeley campus beginning at 5:00
p.m. starting at 6:30 p.m. they'll start
distributing unclaimed or forfeited
tickets right now I think they're only
about 15 tickets actually but if that
changes then be first in line to receive
all of those because I have a feeling
there might be more than a few unclaimed
tickets I think that they're gonna be a
lot of people on the Left who reserved
tickets just to make sure that there are
seats that are empty so if you really
want to get in then go over to go over
to Memorial Stadium box office at the
see Berkeley campus beginning at 5:00
p.m. tomorrow and I will see you there
because it should be a lot of fun widely
anticipated a lot of media coverage of
this particular speech and I'm very much
looking forward to seeing all of you so
that is that is exciting stuff okay
so Hillary Clinton is doing her own book
junket she will not leave and this is
the worst thing in the world for the
Democrats because she was such a deeply
unpopular candidate that she really lost
the election more than Donald Trump on
it and I say that you know knowing that
that Trump may have been the only
Republican candidate who could beat her
that's not a rip on Trump this is just
to point out how unpopular Hillary
Clinton was she won fewer votes fewer
votes in Michigan then Donald sorry
Donald Trump won fewer votes in Michigan
and won the state than George W Bush won
in 2004 in Michigan and George W Bush
lost the state of Michigan that doesn't
demonstrate a vast Trump movement it
demonstrates everyone dislikes Hillary
Clinton same thing in Wisconsin Mitt
Romney actually outperformed Donald
Trump in Wisconsin in 2012 Mitt Romney
lost the state Trump won the state why
no one showed up to vote for this lady
no one showed up to vote for her so she
now comes along and she is gonna give
her explanation for why she lost it
naturally the explanation for why she
lost is because everyone is mean to her
it's just the end of the world
everyone is cruel and mean and vicious
her book came out yesterday and
apparently it is a heaping pile of
garbage there are amusing parts of it
I will admit I've read some of the
sections of it I haven't had a chance to
pick it up as of yet it's been a bit of
a busy week and I mean frankly if I can
somehow put it off to the point where it
becomes irrelevant to the news that be
Gregg's I would not want to spend four
hours reading her book but she is
blaming everyone I think my favorite
part of this of this book is there's a
quote that came out from her book that
is just astonishing where she just
completely misses how it is that the
Orwell novel 1984 what it was about so
that she actually writes this in her
book attempting to define reality is a
core feature of authoritarianism this is
what the Soviets did when they erased
political dissidents from historical
photos this is what happens in George
Orwell's classic novel 1984 when a
torturer holds up four fingers and
delivers electric shocks until as a
prisoner sees five fingers is order the
goal is to make you question logic and
reason and to sow mistrust or Trump as
with so much he does it's about simple
dominance so
basically says the big problem in 1984
is that it's supposed to make you
distrust that Trump's stick is to make
you distrust the press and the
authorities
just like in 1984 which is not what 1984
is about that's about why you should not
trust the press and the authorities the
entire book is about not trusting the
press and the authorities but Hillary
Clinton is nearly as bad at literary
analysis apparently as she is at things
like running for office okay so here is
Hillary doing her stack sheet she first
of all rips the press she starts off
with it's the presses fault it's all the
presses fault they they were just mean
to me if they hadn't been so cruel then
I would have won this election but I
don't think the press did their job in
this election with very few exceptions
so the hard questions about what was
real and what was realistic and what
could happen with the right kind of
election outcome we're never really
joined and so you know I found it
frustrating obviously because I think I
could have defended and lifted up a lot
of what I believed we could do but
really Ezra when you get 32 minutes in a
whole year to cover all policy how does
that work okay so tell me if she wanted
to talk policy but the media were just
too mean
now what's hysterical about this is that
essentially what Hillary Clinton is
doing is she sang the entire 2016
election was wait for it fake news right
she's suggesting that the media didn't
do their jobs the media were all part of
this evil conspiracy to stop her now I
remember when there was a guy named
Donald Trump and he said this all the
time and continues to say it all the
time and the media say how dare Trump
how dare he insult us this way but
Hillary Clinton says the same thing and
they just sit there and take it well
she's probably right you know maybe we
didn't do our jobs this time maybe we
should have been more sycophantic the
big problem for Hillary Clinton and the
Democrats is that the media were so sick
of fancy during the primaries they
refused to acknowledge what a bad
candidate she was so by the time she was
exposed to the light of day she's just
withered in the light of day if the
media had been honest about what a
terrible candidate she was early on the
chances that she would have not won the
nomination would have been exceedingly
exceedingly low I mean the media bias is
always to the left the best example of
this today there's an amazing tweet from
Christian Lisa over at CNN sometimes I
think Chris Chili's does some
interesting stuff but he tweeted
something today that's just incredible
here's what he tweeted quote The Today
Show did Ted Cruz porn video and Seattle
mayor resignation in its first 10
minutes banner day for politicians and
why do I bring this up because when he
says the Today Show did the Ted Cruz
porn video in Seattle mayor resignation
you have to understand what those
stories are to understand how biased the
media is Hillary says the media are
biased against her and Democrats okay
that's insane
the Ted Cruz porn video no Ted Cruz was
not in a porn video no Ted Cruz was not
caught watching a porn video one of his
interns liked a porn video on his
Twitter account that he doesn't even run
okay that's the Ted Cruz porn video
story that was worthy of Chris Chile's
his tweet and what is this Seattle mayor
resignation story that's Democrat Mayor
Ed Murray of Seattle who's a garbage
mayor he had to resign because there was
a fifth allegation of child molestation
against him child molestation okay mo
allegedly molested five kids okay and
here he is and Marie resigning but how
is that characterized by Christian ISA
as Seattle mayor resignation would you
get from that that he was resigning
because of alleged molestation is that
what you would get from that if you just
read those two phrases Ted Cruz porn
video and Seattle mayor resignation
which one of those do you think would
actually include a sex scandal have you
just read those two phrases the cruise
one right but the cruise things and
nothing the Seattle mayor just had to
resign he was by the way an up and comer
in democratic circles there was talk
about him running for governor of the
state of Washington ed Murray he's I
think the first openly gay mayor of
Seattle his $15 minimum wage guy in
Seattle progressive hero molested
allegedly five children five underage
people and Chris chillyzack
characterizes that a Seattle mayor
resignation but no we're supposed to
believe that Hillary really she was the
one who's treated roughly by the media
not Republicans not Trump it was really
Hillary Clinton then Hillary said you
know who else is to blame you know who
else is to blame for all of this I'll
tell you it was James Comey James Comey
was so mean here's Hillary Clinton
explaining I believe absent Comey
I might have picked up one or two points
among white women I'll give you the
example I use in the book so before the
Comey letter in October 28
I was 26 points ahead in the
Philadelphia suburbs that could have
only happened if I had a big vote from
women Republican women independent women
a week later 211 days later I win the
Philadelphia suburbs by 13 points I
needed to win by 18 points to be able to
counterbalance the rest the state that
wasn't just me that's how Democrats win
Pennsylvania in presidential campaigns
it stopped my momentum and it hurt me
particularly among women and I have so
much anecdotal evidence for this and now
researchers are starting to pull some of
this together you know all of a sudden
the husband turns the way I told you
she's gonna be in jail you don't want to
waste your vote you know the boyfriend
turns to the girlfriend and says she's
gonna get locked up don't you hear she's
gonna get locked up I mean all of a
sudden it becomes a very fraught kind of
conflictual experience what I love here
also the statement from Hillary Clinton
ear that it's all the evil men who are
telling their women these stupid women
if only the stupid women wouldn't listen
to their men it's their men who are
turning them and saying she's gonna be
locked up and the women are going Oh
darlin okay I guess I won't vote for her
and more like that's how Hillary Clinton
actually pictures her own female voters
I can't imagine why this lady lost I
cannot imagine why this deeply unlikable
human being lost then she says it wasn't
just Comey was also Russian meddling so
first of all just to point something out
about the the Comey thing yes James
Comey botched this thing all the way
through but if you recall the boxer he
started with him not indicted her in the
first place not recommending indictment
in the first place by actively changing
the standard of law back in July instead
of just handing over his recommendation
to Loretta Lynch he did the bidding of
Barack Obama right he basically was
writing her exoneration statement before
he even interviewed her you don't get to
complain about James Comey when it's
James commis fault that you were even
running competitively up until the end
of the election cycle it wasn't just
calling me though and it wasn't just the
press it was also the Russians the
Russkies the evil Rooskies you notice
there's one person who's missing in all
of these calculations her name runs as
Miller Eve Linton
yeah but Hiller here is Hillary Clinton
explaining that it was the Russkies they
they won't have to take her out election
was how effective
the Russians through WikiLeaks were in
weaponizing information against me and
how they were getting really good
political advice about placement both
Geographic and platform from somebody
and we'll leave it at that yeah but we
didn't really see that that was not
clear to us at the time in the campaign
and in retrospect you know we saw how if
you analyze Google searches they were
spiking in places that had been sort of
swing had ended up voting for President
Obama but were you know subject to being
persuaded by the other side
WikiLeaks searches were off the charts
people were trying to understand and
they were trying to make sense of some
of the stuff they were hearing on their
Facebook you know feeds or a friend
lovely invocation here by the weapon
that they were cleverly weaponizing
WikiLeaks okay I was there
well WikiLeaks did is they just released
giant caches of documents the idea that
they were strategic strategically
releasing portions of them in various
outlets just is not true that's not how
WikiLeaks worked they would dump a bunch
of documents than people like me and my
staff would crowdsource them okay that
was just stuff that happened during the
election cycle but it was also the
Russians and it wasn't the fault of the
DNC for not actually protecting their
servers it was the Russians it wasn't
Hillary Clinton's fault in any way it
was that Hillary Clinton was victimized
by the Russians so now here are the
people she was blamed the press James
Comey the Russians and now we're about
to find out that it was sexism and
misogyny that's really what happened
here as people don't like women right as
people don't like women it wasn't even
like Hillary Clinton and so they'll they
don't like women in general like white
women who by the way went for Donald
Trump by a pretty wide margin it's that
white women hate women that's really the
problem here I was really quite taken
aback at the attitude and the behavior
of my general election opponent because
he made no bones about it literally he
was so sexist and not just about me but
about his Republican woman opponent his
women and reporters on TV and elsewhere
so it was really a part of the
atmosphere and I want not just
but men as well to know this is endemic
sexism and misogyny are still endemic
we've made progress but we can't allow
ourselves to go backward and as I point
out in the book
it never was just about me I happen to
have the big bullseye on my head but it
was about women and in the months since
we've seen reports out of Silicon Valley
and other businesses as well as politics
we're distinguished women like Elizabeth
Warren or Kamala Harris or Kirsten
Gillibrand or you know others in the
media are being treated to a level of
overt sexist okay this is absurd people
don't like Hillary Clinton something I
don't like women
that's ridiculous okay Kamala Harris is
only being talked about for the
presidency because she's a woman she's
been in the Senate for five minutes and
done nothing Elizabeth Warren being
talked about for president is an
absurdity I know Elizabeth Warren she's
a professor at Harvard Law School and I
was there okay the idea that Elizabeth
Warren is being talked about as a
presidential candidate is an absurdity
kirsten gillibrand these are absurdities
but the idea that these are being
treated oh it's that sexism was unlocked
in the last election cycle no what
happened is that people got tired of
people like Hillary Clinton labeling
them sexist and they didn't care what
Trump had to say anymore that's what
happened here people had a choice right
they could either take Trump with yes
some of his sexism but at least he
wasn't calling them sexist or they could
take Hillary Clinton who's lecturing
them every single day about how they
hated women and that was an easy choice
for most people but no it's that
Americans are sexist Americans are
brutal and sexist that's the real issue
here I don't remember Hillary Clinton
speaking out the same way about any of
the various Republican women over over
the course of her over the course I've
heard of long illustrious career
I remember her speaking out the same way
when she was targeting Juanita Broderick
when she was targeting Kathleen Willey
when she was targeting Monica Lewinsky I
remember her speaking out the same way
in favor of women obviously so I love
this revisionist history that it's all
about Americans decided they hated women
just like Donaghy C Coates has said
Americans decided they hated black
people Hillary says Americans decided
that they hated women but it's not just
that Hillary also blamed Bernie Sanders
and we'll get to that in just a second
again everyone has to be blamed and the
reason this is important folks is
because I don't think the Democratic
Party has actually moved beyond this
mentality I think they are stuck in a
rut
they're stuck in a place where they
basically want to divorce from the
American people over this election cycle
I'll explain in just a second but first
I want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at the u.s. ECA so we hear the
stories in the news all the time where a
guys at home and somebody tries to break
into his house knee has to shoot them
and then the police wrongly arrest them
and he ends up in the court system we
hear this all the time well right now
you need to protect yourself and you can
take a simple rewarding journey to
concealed-carry and home defense
confidence with the 2017 concealed carry
and family defense guide that is the
concealed carry and family defense
guidance from the US concealed carry
Association it is 100% free in it you'll
learn how to detect attackers before
they see you how to survive a mass
shooting the safest and most dangerous
places to sit in a restaurant how to
responsibly own and store a gun even if
you have little kids and a whole lot
more these are all super practical tips
it is well worth reading it is 164 pages
so it's pretty comprehensive it comes
with a bonus audio version so you can
even listen in your car I know you like
listening to the podcast you can listen
to this in your car as well this
life-changing guide comes 100% free for
a limited time you also get a bonus home
defense checklist go to defend my family
now calm right now defend my family now
calm and register for a hundred percent
free instant access
that's defend my family now calm defend
my family now to calm you seca makes
sure that you are protected in case you
actually have to pull the trigger and
prepares you for the situation in which
you may have to pull the trigger and how
to best protect yourself again defend my
family now calm right now for 100% free
access to their 2017 concealed carry and
family defense guide super cool stuff go
and check it out defend my family now
dot-com so Hillary also is very upset
with Bernie Sanders
so she said yesterday and that she beat
Bernie Sanders in a landslide
during the interview with NPR she said
she totally rejects that Bernie Sanders
was the guy who's supposed to win the
nomination should I find this criticism
from Sanders supporters to be so
off-base he's not even a Democrat right
so this is the big problems that he's
not even a Democrat he said she said he
and his followers attacks on him he kept
getting more and more personal despite
him asking me not to attack him
personally and you know I really regret
that but now he's got a chance to prove
he's something other than a spoiler and
that is to help other Democrats I don't
know if he will or not but I'm hoping he
will right so there she is attacking
Bernie Sanders everyone has to be
attacked she attacks voters too
right finally she ends up attacking
voters this I think
is probably the best portion of her
pathetic book it's pretty a spectacular
here's what she has to say in her book
she says since November more than two
dozen women of all ages but mostly in
their twenties had approached me in
restaurants theaters and stores to
apologize for not voting or not doing
more to help my campaign I responded
with four smiles and tight nods on one
occasion an older woman dragged her
adult daughter by the arm to come talk
to me in order her to apologize for not
voting which she did head bowed in
contrition I wanted to stare right in
her eyes and say you didn't vote how
could you not vote you abdicated your
responsibility as a citizen at the worst
possible time and now you want me to
make you feel better of course I didn't
say any of that these people were
looking for absolution that I just
couldn't give we all have to live with
the consequences of our decisions whoa
whoa there's only one word for that okay
and it's not it's a five letter word and
it's and it's not something I wish to
say I mean that's that's really nasty
stuff right somebody comes up to you and
they say I wish I had done more and your
first reaction is you little pissant if
you've done more to serve me me the
mistress of all evil then I would be
sitting in the White House right now
it's your fault you you didn't work hard
enough I work plenty hard sure I took a
nap every day sure I clapped into a van
sure I was terrible in debates sure I
was mechanical and awful and nasty and
called half of Americans deplorable z--
but it's you you didn't get out and vote
you and I'm not gonna provide you
absolution I am like the Pope and I will
never provide you absolution
I will never provide you absolution okay
it's no wonder and then Hillary finally
finishes up by saying listen I'm not
going anywhere
you think I'm gonna leave I'm not
leaving and I'm telling you I'm not
going and she won't leave right I mean
she has nothing better to do with her
time what's she gonna do wander around
in the woods like Bigfoot so she's just
gonna stick around sinking her claws
into whatever Democrat starts to move
toward the top pretending she's helping
them but actually hurting them Hillary
is electoral poison and much worse than
Barack Obama was and Obama didn't help
anyone get elected Hillary's even worse
because at least people liked Obama or
at least people pot Obama was cool
people think Hillary Clinton is awful
and the more people see of her the
better so yeah I totally am in favor of
Hillary Clinton sticking around I think
it's great here she is explaining and
that she's not going any
where she she won't go she just won't
like Jennifer Holliday in Dreamgirls
here she is there are many people
including some Democrats who would be
happier if Hillary Clinton stayed in the
woods didn't write this book didn't
reopen the wounds of 2016 well they're
gonna be disappointed because I think
it's important for people with my
experience and my insight into what went
on in the campaign but more generally
about our country to speak out Clinton
says she is done running for office but
she plans to keep speaking up oh please
please do please do the thing is that
Hillary Clinton as just a human being is
an incredibly vindictive person and you
can sense the vindictiveness of the
Democrats in her issues a good avatar
for their vindictiveness that what they
really are about is castigation of the
other if they really wanted to win
they'd run somebody like Joe Biden right
okay I'm just I don't make a habit of
giving advice to Democrats if you wanted
to win you'd run somebody who didn't
spend their time ripping on Americans as
a bunch of no nothing sexist bigoted
racist homophobes who wouldn't get out
and vote for you because I deserved it
but unfortunately that's not something
that Democrats are doing I think Sarah
Huckabee Sanders actually got this
exactly right yesterday she said it's
kind of sad it's a little bit sad right
here is Sarah Huckabee Sanders doing
that I think it's pretty clear to all of
America I think it's sad that after
Hillary Clinton ran one of the most
negative campaigns in history and lost
and the last chapter of her public life
is going to be now defined by propping
up book sales with false and reckless
attacks and I think that that's a sad
way for her to continue it is pretty sad
and thank God for the sadness of the
Democrats because otherwise they might
actually be competent to this now
there's some conflicting information
about what Democrats here are going to
do so Politico has a big piece today I
got him to edward isaac doe beer
reporting the democrats are having
trouble they think that that trump may
in fact be Teflon that using trump as
sort of the the rallying point for their
crowd is not going to do it here's what
he has to say he says data from a range
of focus groups and internal polls in
swing states paint a different picture
for the Democratic Party heading into
the 2018 midterms and one
20 presidential election it suggests
Democrats are naive if they believe
Trump's historically low approval
numbers mean a landslide is coming so
what's the big problem well there are a
bunch
first off Bernie Sanders's economic
program is not convincing to people so
today it came out that a bunch of
Democrats I've written about this and
talked about it yesterday a bunch of
Democrats Elizabeth Warren Kamala Harris
Gillibrand Wilson jump on board all of
the front Cory Booker all of the front
running 2020 Democratic candidates are
talking about embracing Bernie Sanders
Medicare for all plan okay this is
really stupid strategy for a general
election it's really dumb people do not
trust the idea of a government takeover
of the health care system they didn't
like Obama care and so the Democrats are
actually doing something worse they're
talking about a full government takeover
of the government health care system
throwing lots of people off their
insurance because you have to pay for
this somehow and you some have to force
doctors to take Medicare insurance in
the first place the only way to do that
is by getting rid of the competitors in
terms of reimbursement rates you're
gonna have to force people off their
insurance that's what Medicare for all
would probably mean but Democrats are
pushing that but they're also actively
undercutting the their own point when
they when they did Obamacare they said
listen Obamacare is not gonna be about
single-payer we're not moving towards
single-payer guys I mean that's how dare
you
that's not President Obama said this
well this this is you know first step
toward making health care better but
we're not looking at single-payer and
now you've got every Democrat in the
world saying single-payer is on the
table the American people don't want any
of that Democratic Democrats in the base
do radical Democrats in the base want
all that but nobody in middle America
wants a nationalized health care system
but Democrats are moving to the left on
these economic programs in order to get
that base revved up for the full-on
election cycle big mistake big mistake
I'll explain to you the other mistakes
Democrats are making why they're taking
their lead from a combination of Bernie
Sanders and Hillary Clinton which is a
really terrible combination in just a
second but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at my Patriots
supply so right now you look at the
headlines as a hurricane in Texas there
was a hurricane in Florida there are
tornadoes hitting the middle of the
country there's a possibility that North
Korea is developing an intercontinental
ballistic missile tipped with nuclear
weapons and all of that means that the
very least you should have some food in
your house in case things go bad it's
not too much to ask for 99 bucks you get
a hundred and two servings of breakfast
lunches and dinners from my Patriot
supply get their new survival food
supply for just 99 bucks
less than $1 per serving order now at
888 803 1413 888 803 1413 or online at
preparer with Ben Calm it's 99 bucks
plus free shipping prepare with Ben's
calm my Patriot supply believes in
old-fashioned values of good folk so go
over and work with them at 8 8 8 8 o 3
14 13 8 8 8 8 o 3 14 13 prepare with
Ben's calm again protecting your family
for 99 bucks is a no-brainer you store
the food you don't worry about it ever
again people at the office say it tastes
like home cooking so it's good stuff and
there you see how the shelves basically
empty anytime there's any sort of
disaster don't be the person who's
caught left holding the empty bag
goto instead my Patriot supply prepare
with Ben calm its prepare with Ben calm
okay so as I say the Democrats are now
lashing out at the American public and
that's what we've seen for the last
seven months
they just keep the women's March is a
lashing out at the American public the
support for the black lives matter
movement it's a lashing out at the
American public we're seeing a
consistent lashing out at the American
public and it's really ugly and that's
what's driving people into Trump's camp
so what are their new strategies to
fight from well they're trying to move
way left on economics like Bernie
Sanders but as the as political rights
many of the ideas party leaders have
latched on to in an attempt to appeal to
their lost voters free college tuition
raising the minimum wage to 15 bucks
even Medicaid for all tests poorly among
voters outside the base and the reason
that they test poorly among voters
outside the base one reason is because
this is all basic class warfare stuff
right the idea is there's someone
screwing you and we're going to rectify
that situation well vilification and
nastiness is not going to help you it's
funny in 2016 there was this general
idea that Trump was the nasty guy and
Hillary was the candidate of up left no
you basically had two nasty people going
at one another and and Hillary was
actually more alienating to two
Americans than then even Donald Trump
was which is an amazing statement worse
for Democrats Trump is actually being
given credit for the continuing strong
economy according to Politico and
personal attacks on him have been so
variegated meaning that they've been so
diffused that they dilute the message
entirely voters actually don't care that
Trump fibs because they feel like
Democrats think of them badly like who
would you prefer to hang out with the
guy who tells you fish stories but is
nice to you or the person who rails
against you for being a racist sexist
pig and homophobe who needs his soul
hey obviously there's a reason that the
Trump is more popular than some of the
Democratic program and all of the
attempts to paint Trump is a closet and
white supremacists have failed too
because again the Democrats are just so
extreme right I explained this to Don
Lemon on CNN I'm amazed the Democrats
haven't picked up on this after the
Charlottesville incident when Donald
Trump I thought did a terrible job of
handling it instead of Democrats staying
on that Trump immediately swiveled to
defending Confederate statues and
Democrats like the fools they are
decided to follow him there that's a
losing issue for them and they're so
radical that they're actually justifying
a lot of what Trump had to say about the
statutes right from said once you get
rid of the Confederate statues the next
move is to get rid of the Jefferson
statues
today report from Charlottesville
students at the University of Virginia
have now draped in black tarp the Thomas
Jefferson statue Thomas Jefferson
founded the University of Virginia he
founded it okay now they're draping his
statue with a black tarp and you wonder
why people are resonating to Trump hey
Trump also has the advantage on
immigration and trade in these focus
groups as well the biggest problem for
Democrats is that is is not Trump it's
them
they come off as people who look down
their noses at everyday Americans who
see Trump voters as losers and as morons
who see people who didn't even vote for
Hillary Clinton has to be alienated
right this is how they see Americans and
Americans pick up on this there's
nothing that people pick up on more
quickly than a sneer
if you sneer at people people pick up on
it incredibly quickly and people didn't
feel like Trump was sneering at them
they may have felt like Trump was
sneering at the media because he was
sneering and Democrats because he was
they may have felt like Trump was
tearing and fellow Republicans because
he was in fellow candidates but they
didn't feel like he was sneering at them
and they got the feeling that Hillary
Clinton was sneering at them and
Democrats are having a tough time
getting out of that right so their
alternative was okay well if we can't
stop sneering at Americans at least
we'll castigate Trump is evil but Trump
is actually undercut that a little bit
because now he's working with Democrats
how do you castigate Trump is Hitler
when you're making a deal with them when
you're going to the White House there's
a meeting today between Pelosi and
Schumer and Trump now I'm not saying
that's good politics for Trump I think
that making deals with Pelosi and
Schumer is what he was elected not to do
but for Democrats it's very difficult
for them to make the simultaneous case
that Trump has to be stopped because
he's so evil and then they go and work
with present
Trump so may not be the Trump is is
Teflon so much as Trump is rubber and
the Democrats are glue and whatever they
throw at him
bounces off him and sticks back to them
now here's here's the truth I want to
mitigate this statement a little bit do
I think that the Republicans have the
upper hand going into 2018 I think you'd
be foolish to think that I look at the
data and what I see is Democrats winning
some victories and possibly taking the
house right now the generic democrática
the generic ballot has Democrats up
anywhere from six to eight points in the
congressional race there's a lot of talk
in 2005 about George W Bush was Teflon
too and then in 2006 he got blown out
and in 2008 Barack Obama took office
with a Democratic majority in the House
and the Senate and nearly a
supermajority in the Senate okay so it's
a little bit early and it's worth noting
that there are statistics that cut in
favor of Democrats here so on the
question of who fights for people like
me trumping the Democrats were split at
50% each in February Democrats are now
ahead by 17 points that's a big gap that
they've opened up right there and we are
seeing some Republicans retiring because
they don't like working with Trump and
because they're afraid they're gonna be
primary and we are seeing special state
elections in places like Oklahoma swing
Democrat there's a +31 Democrat state
seat Republican states in Oklahoma
yesterday it swung for the Democrats
okay that's that is not good news for
Republicans all that said though the
Democratic program right now is not
geared towards success it's not geared
toward success specifically because of
the scorn if they don't get rid of the
scorn that Hillary that the drips off of
Hillary they're gonna have a problem
they need a candidate with authenticity
who actually does not sneer at the
American people and feel like they are
owed this position if they don't do that
then they're gonna be in serious trouble
now I want to talk about what's going on
with the ongoing attempt by outside
forces to manipulate President Trump on
both sides but before that you're gonna
have to go over and subscribe I also
talked about ESPN and we'll talk about
well we'll talk about the iPhone X the
iPhone 10 release we'll talk about all
those things but first you have to go
over to Daley wire.com and subscribe for
$9.99 a month you can get a subscription
to daily wire that comes with my show
live it comes with our daily wire
mailbag which happens on Fridays we're
doing a special Q&A next Tuesday that
you can be part of if you're a member of
The Daily wire team for 19
to get Andrew Klavan show live as well
that starts at 10:30 today Pacific time
to get Andrew Michel Knowles's show at
12:30 Pacific time today so you get all
of those things for free when you
subscribe at $9.99 a month which is
awesome and right now if you get the
annual subscription $99 a year which is
a better deal than $9.99 a month by a
good twenty dollars or so look at that
math right there in my head then you
also get this the leftist here's how to
call tumblr the greatest of all beverage
vessels something you will treasure
forever and when you are when you are
dead and your children cremate you they
will put your ashes in it and leave it
on the mantle so you that I mean if
you're gonna be buried in this thing you
may as well get it right now leftist
here's how to recall tumblr you get that
when you get the annual subscription
please go over to youtube and subscribe
to our channel that always helps us plus
go over to iTunes or SoundCloud hit
subscribe leave us a review the reviews
do help with the iTunes ranking so we
always appreciate it we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
never talks a lot about the Democratic
failures how they're going to try Bernie
Sanders economics which is not popular
and does not hold up with the American
people and how they've tried Barack
Obama intersectionality and have a scorn
that Hillary Clinton holds for American
voters is infused throughout the
Democratic Party because they just can't
believe that Americans would have
elected Donald Trump but on the other
side of the aisle there's a lot of
confusion with regard to President Trump
what's he gonna do now so there's a big
meeting today between Trump and Pelosi
and Schumer he had a meeting last night
with a bunch of people Republicans and
Democrats about his tax reform bill and
then he tweeted something out about tax
reform go Congress go okay if the extent
of Trump negotiating on tax reform is
going to be him tweeting go Congress go
it's gonna be very difficult for
anything to get done we already tried
this exact plan with health care it did
not work Trump's gonna have to be more
involved than that the problem is that
Pelosi and Schumer offered him an easy
way out because they come to him they
say we'll pass stuff we'll put our name
on it with you you'll get great plaudits
in the new york times it'll be awesome
so we have to be very wary the White
House yesterday came out and said Trump
has always been in favor of amnesty
seriously the White House actually said
that okay I was there this is not true
this is it I know that there's an
attempt right now to try to prop up
Trump on the immigration issues it's
just not real so yesterday Drudge Report
put up a big headline about how Trump
was finally gonna start paving the way
to building the law building the wall
yeah not really okay so here's what it
said from K VOA the Department of
Homeland Security has issued a waiver
it's waived certain laws regulations and
other legal requirements to ensure the
expeditious construction of barriers in
the vicinity of the international border
near collec so California the waiver was
published in the Federal Register today
so is that really a waiver that we're
gonna get started building on the wall
well not really because from 2005 to
2008 the department actually used that
waiver authority five times okay wasn't
wall built though a wall was not built
that does not mean that we are gonna be
building new wall it means that they are
replacing current wall they're replacing
border fence that currently exists so no
that is not the building of the new wall
don't be fooled by the headlines well
there's also an attempt that's quite
fascinating
a lot of Republicans on various sides of
the aisle have decided that it's
imperative to flatter Trump into backing
their positions so
the fascinating thing to watch right now
is that Steve Bannon who sees himself
over at Breitbart is sort of the avatar
of trumpism right the great philosopher
king of trumpism he's been pushing Trump
on some things that I agree with
actually and some things I don't agree
with but the people who are who are not
on Team Bannon a lot of those people who
want Trump to do different things
they're now using Bannon as a foil and
they're picking on Van Daan's criticism
of Trump in order to drive a wedge in
other words I think a lot of people have
now figured out Trump's gig
his whole shtick his whole shtick is if
you praise him he likes you and if you
criticize him he doesn't
that's Trump's entire stick so a lot of
people are basically now pecked picking
up on this and they're trying to find
instances where their own political
opponents have attacked Trump and then
they're trying to highlight to trump
those people are attacking him so he'll
move away from their policies good
example of this so Sarah Huckabee
Sanders who is obviously in the
administration a lot of people in the
administration are not big band and fans
he was just out stat a couple of weeks
ago she Steve Bannon had said that
Trump's biggest mistake was firing James
Comey the FBI director Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is trying to drive a wedge
between Bannon and Trump here she's
doing it I think that everybody knows
exactly where the president stands on
that issue the president is proud of the
decision that he made the president was
100% right in firing James Comey he knew
at the time that it could be bad for him
politically but he also knew and felt he
had an obligation to do what was right
and do what was right for the American
people and certainly the men and women
at the FBI
I think there's no secret Comey about
his own self admission leaked privileged
government information weeks before
President Trump fired him coming
testified that an FBI agent engaged in
the same practice they'd face serious
repercussions I think he set his own
stage for himself on that front his
actions were improper and likely could
have been illegal coming leaked memos to
the New York Times your own outlet he
politicized an investigation by
signaling he would exonerate Hillary
Clinton before he ever interviewed her
or other key witnesses so then it's
smart for Huckabee Sanders to do all
this because she's defending Trump now
from Manning but here's here's the
giveaway here's what Mitch McConnell is
doing today okay here's the Senate
leadership fund they're specifically
going after Steve Bannon because Bannon
is trying now to undermine a lot of
Mitch McConnell's favorite candidates so
here's what McConnell said Senate
leaders
funf president and CEO Stephen law today
released the following statement in
response to Steve ban and calling James
commies firing the biggest mistake in
modern political history quote Steve
Annan is dead wrong every fact that has
come out about James commies handling of
the Clinton email investigation has
affirmed the rightness of President
Trump's decision now do you think that
Mitch McConnell actually believes that
or do you think that Mitch McConnell is
trying to play the president in Mitch
McConnell is pretty clearly trying to
play the president you're gonna get more
of this the Democrats are trying to play
Trump by praising him Mitch McConnell is
trying to play trump by attacking Bannon
for attacking Trump
everyone knows the game now and the game
is personal it is not political it'll be
interesting to see how it plays out okay
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate and then a quick
Bible talk so things that I like I'm
doing children's movies this week
because I just have to be in that mood
man I mean like going to Berkeley it's
it's gonna be fun and all but it's also
kind of stressful and so watching
children's movies with my kids or my kid
because one of them is too young to
watch movies is is really fun my
daughter right now is obsessed with
Bambi she loves Bambi this was the
Golden Age of Walt Disney's films I
believe this was the third Walt Disney
film I think that it went Snow White
Pinocchio Bambi in order but Bambi is a
masterpiece I mean it's just the artwork
is a masterpiece again the the the
attempt to promulgate traditional values
in Bambi is very strong the idea of the
fathered year and the mother deer and
the and the baby deer Bambi growing up
into the protector of the herd right
males are there to protect is the very
strong theme in Bambi mothers are there
to nurture males are there to protect is
a very very strong theme in Bambi here's
a little bit of the preview such a
charming film
[Applause]
[Music]
well is me the world's greatest
storyteller brings the world's greatest
love story to the screen Bambi the story
that proves that love can be loaded with
rocks
well what they're twitterpated whoever
painted nearly everybody gets
twitterpated in the springtime it's not
gonna happen to me
me neither it can happen to anybody for
example you are walking along minding
your own business when all of a sudden
you run smack into a face begins
to get weak in the knees you know I mean
the movie today would be skits
heteronormative it's too dark for
children I mean Bambi's mom gets shot
halfway through the film I mean it's a
very dark film but again and teaches
some life lessons that I think yeah
remember people just tougher that okay
Bambi came out in 1942 we were already
in the middle of World War two a lot of
dads were off to war and the idea that
that you know it was the mail job to
protect the civilized society I think
it's pretty clear actually in the film I
don't think that it's particularly well
hidden I'm wrong about this being the
third film this is actually film number
five because it goes Snow White in the
Seven Dwarves Pinocchio Fantasia which
is also a masterpiece a Dumbo which is a
masterpiece Bambi which is a masterpiece
those all I mean those five films are
all masterpieces they're all amazing
films and then you get in sort of the
second iteration of Disney in 1950 right
that's when you get Cinderella Alice in
Wonderland Peter Pan a lady in the
Sleeping Beauty all of these are good
movies but I don't think they're quite
to the level of the originals and then
you get the dark period for Disney
that's when you get Robin Hood the sword
in the stone the Aristocats they're the
only great film from that particular
period is The Adventures of Robin Hood
but you get the rescuers the Black
Cauldron right movies that no one's ever
seen because they're not good and then
you have kind of the second you have the
the third wave for Disney which is
Beauty and the Beast Aladdin The Lion
King Pocahontas right a lot of great
movies and now it's been taken over by
Pixar but but Bambi is obviously a
phenomenal movie and well worth watching
with your kids especially you can sit
there with the kids so you can
fast-forward through some of the scary
parts okay others okay so time for some
things
that oh one other thing that I like
there is a Barry Weiss column over at
the New York Times that I think is
really terrific talking about my visit
to Berkeley it's well worth reading yes
we have reached the apocalypse when the
New York Times opinion page is defending
my visit to Berkeley basically saying
that you know the left's attempt to lump
everyone is in his Nazis is utterly
absurd great column by Barry Weiss and I
thank her for writing it ok time for a
couple of things that I hate so one of
the things that has happened is that as
our technology gets better we get dumber
we seem to have less purpose in the
world I'm starting to write a book on
this right now we seem to have less
purpose we seem to have less meaning in
our lives and so our technology
continues to grow our science continues
to get better and then we use it for the
stupidest available crap you could
possibly imagine if you can imagine
people saying oh we've developed
technology that allows facial
recognition and we develop technology
that allows us to map your face what
could you use that for you know in in a
good way well maybe you could use it to
help
for example teach autistic kids how to
recognize emotion right now that seems
like a good use of it because a lot of
autistic kids have difficulty
recognizing emotions and faces how
exactly are we going to use it however
the way we are going to use it is we are
going to make ourselves into talking
pieces of poop this was actually in the
Apple iPhone 10 presentation yesterday
in in they're big they're big roll out
the truth that camera also enables new
experiences by bringing emojis to life
by mapping more than 50 facial muscles
in real time so you can be happy or sad
or cross
[Music]
you can be any animated character you
wish to be you can be a talking piece of
poop yeah well welcome to the 21st
century we we may have given up on you
know values and systems we may have
given up on the idea of a God that cares
about you in the universe but on the
other hand we can also we can also make
you we can devolve you to the level of a
talking piece of human feces we can make
that happen for you so that's very
exciting stuff okay other things that I
hate there's a lot of talk today about
firing - Mel Hill Jameel Hill she is a a
host on ESPN she does a truly awful show
with Michael Smith called sd-6
I know because whenever I'm working out
at the gym this thing is on it's a
really crappy show but this is not a
Chrismukkah take of the show which is
indeed garbage Jamil hill came out and
she tweeted this yesterday Donald Trump
is a white supremacist who has largely
surrounded himself with other white
supremacists the height of white
privilege is being able to ignore his
white supremacy because it's of no
threat to you well it's a threat to me
Trump is the most ignorant offensive
president of my lifetime his rise the
direct result of white supremacy period
he is unqualified unfit to be President
he is not a leader and if you were not
white he never would have been elected
okay an ESPN quickly responded with this
statement they said the comments on
Twitter from Jamil Hill regarding the
president do not represent the position
of ESPM we have addressed this with
Jamil she recognizes her actions were
inappropriate okay I hate everything
about this first of all Jamil hill is
wrong the idea that Trump is in a is a
white supremacist is not true Trump is
not good on race issues but the idea
that he himself is a white supremacist
rather than pandering to a group of
white supremacist I think is false you
know maybe it's a distinction without
much of a difference but I think that it
does matter if you're going to attribute
motives to people we should at least be
specific about the motives we attribute
you know this idea that that Trump is is
the root of all racial evil in the
United States is just a repeat of Tana
he's he coats but she has every right to
say it obviously she can say whatever
she wants now yes PN would be well
within its rights to suspend or fire her
they could say listen you just alienated
half our audience you're here to talk
about sports not to talk about Donald
Trump but instead they issue this kind
of milquetoast statement saying they
don't that her her actions were
inappropriate well I don't think they're
actually inappropriate I mean she gets
paid to talk about all this stuff
including politics on her show it seems
kind of ridiculous to me then now ESPN
is backing off with this but do they
think we
watch the network the big promised pan
is happening right now is that I just
want to see the highlights of the
Cleveland Indians winning their 20th
game in the row instead I turn on the TV
and I get Colin Kapernick talked for 45
minutes I get how many gay college
football players are there for 45
minutes I get what's the latest with
Caitlyn Jenner for 45 minutes like I
can't get to the actual highlights
because all you're doing is spending
time talking about stupid political
nonsense that I don't care about in any
in any form and then the SPN is shocked
when shamil hill feels the freedom to go
out and do this now there's another
story that came out yesterday that Linda
Cohen who's a longtime anchor that she
was reportedly suspended because she
spoke out on politics at the network she
said I don't think these politics are
great at the network and the president
John skipper told her not to come to
work and to think about what she said so
she was suspended for saying ESPN was
talking too much politics Jamil Howe was
not suspended for saying Trump was
racist they say here's my feeling about
this Jamil hell shouldn't be fired she
shouldn't be suspended let the audience
make their decision about your mail ho
Linda Cohen certainly should not be
fired or suspended for having the
temerity to point out the stupidity of
ESPN for going full-scale political it's
one of my pet peeves I've been talking
about it for years turning an ESPN into
MSNBC with footballs is just absurd okay
time for a quick Bible talk here so as
we do every week we are going through
portions from the from the prophets and
because in the Jewish community we last
year we went over the entire five books
of Moses piece by piece this year we are
going through the the portions from the
prophets that are associated with them
this is from Isaiah chapter 61 it says
for like the earth which gives forth its
plans and like a garden that causes its
seeds to grow so shall the Lord God
cause righteousness and praise to grow
opposite all the nations there's kind of
an interesting verse the reason it's an
interesting verse is because the idea is
that all things are invested with
potentiality I've been reading too much
Edward feasor that's that book that I
recommend it a couple of days ago and he
talks about the Aristotelian notion that
objects are are imbued with
potentialities that a pen is imbued with
the potential to write that a cup is
imbued with the potential to hold liquid
or to be melted down
we all have potentials right we as human
beings have potentials and the earth has
the potential to give forth plans and a
garden has the potential to to give
forth to give forth the the it seeds to
grow and you have the potential
to be a righteous person and God can
help you reach that potential if you
trust in him but you have to understand
that in the Aristotelian argument that
there is no unmoved that there is an
unmoved mover that that when it comes to
growth that growth requires a mover now
you have freewill imbued in you by God
and you can use that to change your life
you can use that to make your life
better you are you you have potential
just like the earth just like the garden
you have potential
trust in God which really means faith in
your own free will to make decisions
doing that allows you to fulfill that
potential if you sit back and wait for
things to happen for you if you blame
the garden for not growing the seeds if
you blame the earth for not giving forth
the plans if you blame God for your
problems you're not gonna get anywhere
you have to understand that your it is
your job to reach your own potential and
that potential does exist within you and
once you start moving in that direction
I firmly believe that God lends a hand
okay we will be back here tomorrow and
we will preview the speech at Berkeley
so tomorrow is gonna be a big day hope
you're here I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]